GRIM BUSINESS HERE IN EASTERN
KENTUCKY.
I TALKED TO A FAMILY JUST A
LITTLE WHILE AGO WHO DESCRIBED A
HEARTBREAKING SITUATION.
IN THE FIRST PLACE, THEY LIVE UP
HIGH, AND AS YOU TALK TO PEOPLE
AROUND HERE, FOR MANY PEOPLE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LOSING A
HOUSE AND HAVING A HOME, THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE OR DEATH
SIMPLY HAD TO DO WITH HOW HIGH
UP YOUR HOUSE SAT HERE IN
EASTERN KENTUCKY.
AND THEY DESCRIBE THE SITUATION
WHERE AFTER THE RAINS CAME AND
THE FLASH FLOOD STARTED
BUILDING, THEY COULD HEAR THE
CRIES OF NEIGHBORS, PEOPLE
CALLING FOR HELP.
BUT THEY COULDN'T HELP THEM
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T GET ACROSS
THE WATER.
SO CONCERNING SITUATION
CERTAINLY FOR EVERYBODY HERE.
MEANWHILE, YOU TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE GOVERNOR.
WE'RE TOLD THAT HE DID POSTPONE
AN EARLIER FLYOVER TODAY SIMPLY
OUT OF CONCERNS ABOUT THE
WEATHER APPARENTLY GOING TO GO
AT A LATER TIME AND GOING TO
BRIEF REPORTERS.
HE DID GET A COMMITMENT FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, WE'RE TOLD, TO
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
HERE IN 12, 13 COUNTIES IN
KENTUCKY AS THE CLEANUP BEGINS.
OF COURSE, WE'RE STILL TALKING
ABOUT A RECOVERY AT THIS STAGE.
HERE'S THE GOVERNOR NOW TALKING
ABOUT THE SITUATION IN THE STATE
AND HOW IT'S UNPRECEDENTED.
>> WE'VE NEVER SEEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
FOLKS WHO DEAL WITH THIS FOR A
LIVING HAVE BEEN DOING IT FOR 20
YEARS HAVE NEVER SEEN WATER THIS
HIGH.
WHOLE ROADS WASHED OUT.
WE STILL CAN'T GET TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
THERE'S SO MUCH WATER.
THE CURRENT IS SO STRONG, IT'S
NOT SAFE FOR SOME OF THE WATER
RESCUES THAT WE NEED TO DO.
SO WE'LL BE IN THE SEARCH AND
RESCUE CERTAINLY TODAY AND
TOMORROW, AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT A YEAR'S WORTH
AT LEAST OF REBUILDING.
>> Reporter: AND I WOULD SAY
LOOKING AT THE DEVASTATION JUST
HERE ALONG THIS ROAD, MAYBE MORE
THAN A YEAR.
THEY DID BRING IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD, AND THEY SAY THAT
CONTRIBUTED QUITE A BIT TO THE
RESCUE AND RECOVERY EFFORT
YESTERDAY.
BACK TO YOU.
>> YEAH, SO IMPORTANT TO HAVE AS
MUCH HELP AS POSSIBLE.
JOE, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING ME IS KENTUCKY'S
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, JACQUELINE
COLEMAN.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US
THIS MORNING.
I WANT TO PICK UP ON WHAT WE
WERE HEARING THERE BOTH FROM JOE
JOHNS, MY COLLEAGUE, AND ALSO
FROM GOVERNOR BESHEAR.
THE TALK ABOUT NOT BEING ABLE TO
GET TO A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO NEED
TO BE RESCUED BECAUSE OF THAT
RUSHING WATER.
WHAT ABOUT THE COMMUNICATIONS IN
TERMS OF STAYING IN TOUCH WITH
PEOPLE?
ARE THERE COMMUNICATION CONCERNS
STILL THIS MORNING?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME ON AND FOR
BRINGING ATTENTION TO THIS
DEVASTATION IN EASTERN KENTUCKY.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, YES,
THERE ARE MANY EFFORTS ONGOING
AT THE STATE LEVEL, AS WELL AS
IN THE LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS'
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED.
SOME OF THOSE COMMUNICATIONS ARE
OR BEGANIC, THEY ARE NEIGHBORS
-- ORGANIC, THEY ARE FLASHES
REACHING TOUTS NEIGHBORS,
UTILIZING SOCIAL MEDIA, TEXTING,
CALLING TO CHECK ON FAMILY
MEMBERS, AND THOSE MESSAGES ARE
MAKING THEIR WAY TO KENTUCKY
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AS WELL AS
THE STATE POLICE POST IN THE
REGION.
AND THEN THERE ARE SYSTEMS BEING
PUT IN PLACE FOR HOW TO CONTINUE
THE RESCUE, BUT AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE THAT WE GET SUPPLIES
AND FOOD AND ARE ABLE TO OFFER
SHELTER TO VICTIMS WHO MAY NOT
HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO GO.
THE GOVERNOR'S ACTUALLY OPENED
THREE OF OUR STATE PARKS IN THE
EASTERN PART OF THE STATE
SPECIFICALLY TO HOUSE FOLKS WHO
HAVE LOST EVERYTHING AS THEY
WORK TO BEGIN TO REBUILD THEIR
LIVES.
>> IT IS -- THE PICTURES ARE
DEVASTATING.
AND I KNOW IT WILL BE TRAUMATIC
FOR SOME TIME TO COME FOR THOSE
FOLKS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DID JUST APPROVE
THE EMERGENCY DISASTER
DECLARATION.
WHAT WILL THAT -- WHAT DOES THAT
OPEN FOR YOUR STATE, AND HOW
QUICKLY DO YOU THINK YOU COULD
SEE THAT AID AND FUNDING?
>> WELL, THE GOVERNOR MOVED VERY
QUICKLY TO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR RESPONDING
QUICKLY, AS WELL, UNDERSTANDING
HOW DIRE THE SITUATION IS IN
EASTERN KENTUCKY.
WE HAVE 17 COUNTIES THAT HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED.
THE MOST IMPACTED LOOKS LIKE AT
THE MOMENT IT IS BREFFET,
LITKER, AND PERRY COUNTIES.
BY DECLARING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE'RE GOING TO GET NOT
JUST NOW FOR RESCUE AND RECOVERY
MISSIONS, BUT ALSO IN THE LONG
RUN AS WE WORK TO REBUILD, WHICH
IT'S GOING TO BE A LONG ROAD, AS
YOU CAN SEE FROM THESE PICTURES.
THIS IS NOT ANYTHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE AN EASY RECOVERY.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, WE HAVE
THE MOST COMPASSIONATE LEADERS.
WE HAVE THE MOST COMPASSIONATE
AND HARD-WORKING PEOPLE RIGHT
HERE IN KENTUCKY.
AND THE ONLY THING I'VE SEEN
THAT RIVALS THE DEVASTATION THAT
YOU'RE SEEING IN THESE IMAGES IS
TEAM KENTUCKY'S RESPONSE.
WE ARE GOING STAND WITH THESE
FOLKS TODAY, TOMORROW, AND IN
ALL THE DAYS TO COME AS THEY
REBUILD THEIR LIVES.
>> AND THAT COMMUNITY WILL BE SO
IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW, GOVERNOR BESHEAR
EARLIER ON CNN SAID HE DOES
EXPECT THE CURRENT DEATH TOLL,
WHICH IS UP TO 16, HE EXPECTS
THAT WILL LIKELY MORE THAN
DOUBLE INCLUDING SOME CHILDREN.
DO YOU SHARE THOSE CONCERNS?
>> I DO.
AND YOU KNOW, GOVERNOR BESHEAR
AND I, WE ARE -- THE GOVERNOR
AND LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, BUT
HE'S A DAD OF A 12 AND A
13-YEAR-OLD.
I AM THE MOTHER OF A
2 1/2-YEAR-OLD.
AND THE EMPATHY AND THE SHOCK OF
THINKING ABOUT PUTTING YOURSELF
IN THOSE SHOES, WHICH IS WHAT WE
DO AS LEADERS, IS MORE THAN MOST
OF US CAN IMAGINE RIGHT NOW.
I CANNOT IMAGINE LOOKING FOR
FAMILY MEMBERS, ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN AND ELDERLY WHICH ARE
OBVIOUSLY HIGH PRIORITY AT THIS
POINT.
IT'S DEVASTATING.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, THAT NUMBER,
IT CONTINUES TO RISE.
THE FLOOD HAS -- WATERS HAVE NOT
CRESTED YET.
WE'RE STILL HAVING RAINFALL IN
KENTUCKY THAT'S PREVENTED THE
GOVERNOR FROM ACTUALLY DOING A
FLYOVER THIS MORNING.
HE WILL DO IT, BUT WHEN IT'S
SAFE.
AND SO THE TRAGEDY CONTINUES,
BUT WE'VE ALREADY CONDUCTED 50
AIR RESCUE MISSIONS, BOAT
RESCUES, AND WE'RE DETERMINED TO
SAVE AS MANY FOLKS AND TO FIND
AS MANY FOLKS AS WE CAN.
>> REAL QUICKLY BEFORE YOU GO,
BEYOND SOME COOPERATION FROM THE
WEATHER, WHAT IS YOUR BIGGEST
NEED THIS MORNING?
>> OUR BIGGEST NEED IS CERTAINLY
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
WATER AND CLEANING SUPPLIES TO
THE LOCATIONS IN THE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
THOSE ARE BEING SET UP.
THOSE DROP PLACES ARE BEING SET
UP AS WE SPEAK.
BUT TO ANYONE WHO'S WATCHING
THAT FEELS MOVED AND FEELS THE
NEED TO HELP IN SOME WAY, EVERY
DOLLAR YOU CAN DIRECT TO THE
TEAM EASTERN KENTUCKY RELIEF
FUND IS A DOLLAR THAT WILL GO
DIRECTLY TO SUPPORTING THIS
RESCUE MISSION AND HELPING OUR
FELLOW KENTUCKIANS REBUILD.
SO THE WEBSITE IS TEAMEKYFLOODS
FLOODRELIE
FLOODRELIEFFUND.KY.GOV.
KNOW HOW MUCH APPRECIATED IT THE
PEOPLE OF KENTUCKY ARE AND HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE FOR THE SUPPORT,
ALREADY THE OUTPOURING OF
SUPPORT THAT WE'VE SEEN TO MAKE
A PART OF THIS STATE WHO HAS
BEEN -- THAT HAS BEEN LEFT
BEHIND IN THE PAST, UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH WE CARE FOR THEM.
>> LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
JACQUELINE COLEMAN, APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THIS MORNING.
WE WILL, OF COURSE, CONTINUE TO
STAY ON THE STORY, AS WELL.
THANK YOU.